[Musik]
männer war
denn jahres nachweis gelten ist ich war
oft uhr gestartet
herzlich willkommen so salis wenn ja ich
wollte schon immer mal auf türkisch
starten
vielleicht sollte ich auch mal ein
ganzes video auf türkisch machen aber
dann verstehen die meisten egal wir
machen auf deutsch weiter ich mache
heute einen richtig leckeren
schokoladenkuchen einem skateboard
dieses jahr praktisch dieses zusammen
dieses zusammenspiel aus marshmallow und
schokolade und da haben die kinder
freude wenn man sagt dass amor amor und
irgendwo dadurch einfach zwei also eine
abkürzung und da gibt es wirklich ganz
viele rezepte heute geht es im
schokokuchen mit einer marshmallow
kruste also mit abc kruste und ich lass
dir dann wirklich noch ein bisschen
weich dass es so ein bisschen an
manchmal noch erinnert der sehr mag und
der marcel haben sich diesen kuchen
gewünscht dass die beiden sollten ihn
dann auch später auf jeden fall
probieren
ich mache jetzt zuerst einmal dem
schokokuchen der soll ein bisschen an
dem braunen erinnern deswegen so ein
bisschen schokoladig und nicht ganz
lustig er fest aber eben auch richtig
schön saftig für den brownie verwende
ich 200 gramm schokolade 200 g weiche
butter 150 gramm braunem zucker und eine
prise salz 4 eigelb und ein ganzes etwas
tonkabohnen passte 200 gramm mehl und
einen hut teelöffel backpulver 40 gramm
kakaopulver und 100 gramm backfest
eshops zuerst einmal werde ich jetzt die
butter in die rührschüssel geben
die sollte auf jeden fall schön weich
sein und ihr braucht ja auch keine
küchenmaschine ihr könnt es auch mit der
hand berühren oder einfach mit dem
handrührgerät da den braunen zucker und
das salz dazu und die zutaten für ein
paar minuten cremig verrühren und ich
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
zeit bitter schokolade schmelzen dann
nämlich immer eine herren schokolade die
hat nämlich ganz viel kakao anteil ist
nicht ganz so süß das heißt der kuchen
wird richtig schön schokoladig entweder
schmelzer sie jetzt über dem wasserbad
oder einfach in der mikrowelle
[Musik]
die butter zucker massa ist schön
verrührt jetzt kommt die schokolade rein
willst du dir einfließen lassen hat gut
fest und ich hab das gleich aus mit
meiner mama hat das backen früher mehr
spaß gemacht möchte warum sie hatte
keinen treiber und dann bleibt mehr
schokolade übrig zum ausschmücken dass
ich sie dir übrig lassen
bei mir bleibt nichts übrig bitte schön
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier die eier
nacheinander zu und ich habe hier die
vier eigelbe und das ganze weil ich
einfach später die besemer so drauf
machen und habe ich das eiweiß das heißt
ich habe ja im kompletten rezept einfach
alle eier komplett aufgebraucht und habe
einfach keinen rest
[Musik]
der rest geht ziemlich einfach und
schnell jetzt kommt hier noch etwas
tonkabohnen passte rein und dann kann
ich jetzt sie trocknen sie gerade dazu 7
das mehl backpulver und cacau
[Musik]
hier komme jetzt auch die schoko drops
rein hast du dir ein film die übrigen
die ich noch habe die dieser nicht
verstand ich sehe schon dass wir gar
nicht alle reinschieben kommen die dazu
behalten so spielt und jetzt ganz kurz
unterrühren
das wird ein richtiges leckerer braunen
haaren wie seehofer als mit seinem
marshmallow obendrauf manchmal ludlow
möchte ich gleich den teig schreiber
haben kannst du das kürzlich spiele
legen
jetzt will ich den teig einfach in
meinem bett kriegen ein den habe ich
bereits eingestellt und ob es noch ruhig
gestellt und der braune werde zum ofen
vorgebacken und ich kann dann in der
zwischenzeit die besemer zu machen und
dann wird die noch mal mit gebackenen
zum schluss
[Musik]
die hälfte der backzeit ist jetzt vorbei
das heißt ich kann jetzt das pc
vorbereiten für das pc verwende ich für
eiweiß eine prise salz 200 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt und 100 gramm
butter schokolade werde das eiweiß in
die schüssel geben
da kommt das salz dazu geschlagen
dann gebe ich jetzt hier den zucker
langsam dazu und lasse dann die b c
masse für etwa zehn minuten richtig
schön steif schlagen sie soll richtig
glänzen und der zucker soll sich
komplett aufgelöst haben
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die schokolade schmelzen
jetzt ist auch der kuchen gebacken und
wenn ich hier einen zahnstocher
hineinsteckt dann bleibt noch ein
bisschen was hängen das ist aber auch
richtig so denn das ist brown darf noch
so ein bisschen feucht sein also noch
ein bisschen saftig und vor allem wir
daher gleich nochmal weiter gewachsen
also nicht so trocken und nicht zu durch
baken der schnee sieht wunderbar aus
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen vanille
extrakt rein
[Musik]
und hier noch die schokolade
und jetzt nur ganz leicht unter heben so
dass es sich noch nicht komplett
vermischt also wirklich nur so zwei drei
umdrehungen
jetzt kommt die b c masse direkt hier
auf den kuchen auf dem braun und da
jetzt darauf achten vom rand etwas weg
bleiben denn die b&c masse die geht der
erfahrung nach immer noch ein bisschen
auseinander
ich glaube das gefällt meinen jungs das
wird den gut schmecken und den mädels
bisschen nur verteilen aber wirklich so
in der mitte dieser erhöhung lassen wo
sie zwecks wunderbar aus und jetzt
stelle ich am backofen die temperatur
herunter auf 140 grad backen kuchen
fertig lassen dann abkühlen und dann
geht schon ans probieren also echt super
schnell oder
[Musik]
sieht super aus und darf jetzt auf
kühlen
[Musik]
jetzt decke fertig und kann
angeschnitten werden
jungs ihr steht schon in den
startlöchern machen wir stumpf also ich
hoffe es ist so geworden dass er immer
noch schön saftig ist und oben drauf
knuspriger ich glaube das sieht gut aus
[Musik]
wann habe ich das gemacht
ich erinnere mich nicht mehr so erstmal
hier kurz der schocker hollick dessen
gesicht nicht gezeigt werden da ich
meine was selten können so einfach dass
miley überdenken ich machen wenn du dich
nicht zeigen sieht es gut aus da diese
steine jetzt probiert mal dass noch nie
so genossen so sehe ich keine drauf und
zwar entsteht das nur durch die baiser
monster weil der schokolade unter
gehoben wird
aber wir arbeiten alle ja mal ganz
ehrlich ist hier was wünsche ich ehrlich
sagen wir sie nicht schmeckt hat alles
was ich habe 1000
ich hab mir machst du schmeckt man sagt
das ist ja auch immer schmeckt gut aber
machen nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
de mora sagt wenn es schmeckt aber dann
muss er leider hungrig ins bett
nein er darf das sagen dafür schmeckt es
auch so fluffig ich habe deutlich gesagt
die server marshmallow schlaf ich
deswegen so cool
[Musik]
ja es soll mehr so ich habe keinen
marshmallow drin wäre wahrscheinlich
richtung see das ist haben diese these
masse und dieses moskau ist ein
schneller und schokolade
aber ich habe zeit mit baiser gemacht
und praktisch ohne ich habe dasselbe
problem wie das schmeckt einfach alles
was du musst ja besonders wenn es aus
schokolade ist es doch nur neidisch
morath ja mach doch einfach mal wieder
monats fünf minuten und dann lässt die
drei jungs hier probieren okay ja also
sowas so froh wenn mir deine sachen
auszuschütten
dieses rezept findet ihr auch cds -
blog.de das ist unkündbar ohne kündigt
bar restaurant lob ausspricht so auf
settings blog.de falls ihr euch mal
wieder ein rezept wünscht schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
dann probieren wir alle ok morath ja das
kommt ja jetzt einfach besser oder
schlechter schmecken sie gut aus er hat
doch eigentlich schon bis zum nächsten
mal tippte ich gerne wieder was wünschen
er ist gut an